in I truly believe that the reason you
are working a lot during the injury
because you have red hair I mean I want
to say that don't see I'm not I hate to
say but let's be honest that's the own
they got a checkbox you're not talents
know they got a checkbox I don't think
you'd be I don't think you'd be working
or B I don't think you'd be doing a lot
of snow don't get bad bro I'm talented
I'm smart I'm hard-working I'm on every
single night in my [ __ ] life you
think it's the [ __ ] red hair I'll
shave this [ __ ] writer off house
it'll get more work no don't don't Ryan
don't you even start with me right now
okay just because you're on a spin-off
of the Goldbergs on school and it's
gonna do very well which I'm proud of
you for and I would never down you for
that don't take away my ability my hard
work my ethics I have nothing in this
business I came here with no money I
have no family I'm not Jewish
I made it alone I made it alone Brock
hey I know that don't you dare
no I'm dude you're turning the key on
the red Ferrari you want to [ __ ] rat
me out because I will burn out all over
this place I misspoke I misspoke
I fired up bro no I did my mom man you
know better because I've earned this no
I know you've earned did you earn your
position in this game I did with regular
hair here's the thing your regular hair
I'm just laying regular hair all red
everybody knows that a ginger has you I
see you right away you do you do pop
yeah I pop yeah and I stand out okay
guess what I have to deliver harder when
they see your normal-looking hair ass on
stage they just go this is just a normal
goofy looking [ __ ] white guy goofy
I'm not well you are goofy looking oh
there's no doubt who says goofy those
years have been bowing out a little bit
as we gotten older like doors ladies
hard doors that are Olson no death yeah
they've been bawling out audience don't
say Bowie I think we should pin him back
you should tie it you should tie floss
from one side to the other and pull him
back at night no that is a procedure
you've all went out yeah you should
you're like let's say for the reason say
Finn was born with huge yes the Sun
never hits his face okay one guy that
can fly this way so it's like jumbo
let's say something good is it where
that collocation you know what you know
they can't they they snip it and clips
have been pulling back
looks normal well so kids don't get
bullied anymore so they see you would
also die kids you could die you could
dye your hair but they see you want
stage and they go let's see what this
[ __ ] regular Joe Schmoe has to do you
come up there with some of your you know
jokes whatever I know know there some of
them are good i watch actually a couple
nights ago and i thought wow that's
better than you know you used to be okay
and you and you'd sling your jokes and
they go good yeah I'm glad he was good
but he's normal I get up there and they
go what is this what is this guy anyway
and then I [ __ ] murder and they go
wow yeah wow he overcame something do
you have any red head jokes not really
Marland and you had no don't do your
accents my accents are so spot-on though
it's kinda let me ask you a question
seriously yeah
what little boy is freezing outside
because you stole his outfit you stole
his whole outfit look at that little boy
shirt you have on dude this is the
little thing oh I love all sides yeah
but that shirt was a little boy shirt
okay listen
yeah it the stripes that go this way are
flattering they're a horizontal stripes
for those of you listening to this make
my was make my shoulders but it makes
Brian bring out as brought my shoulder
oh my shoulders for the broadness that
they actually are you kind of you look
like you're you know what you did you
look like you put on the outfit and then
grow up that's what you look like that's
what you [ __ ] look like what the [ __ ]
my future oh [ __ ] dude hey put your [ __ ]
I put my son gun you brought this up
yeah cuz I want to ask you I had to put
it I had to put my sunglasses on so
obnoxious cuz your future so bright yeah
that's exactly yeah okay so you get it I
don't get it how could I want to ask you
seriously I want to get I want to get
serious and I want to I want to start
with a question alright start with a
future so bright and it sucks the man I
need to wear sunglasses indoors you
don't I want to start with this question
right let's start with the general I'm
ready right cuz I'm looking at you got
holes in your jeans you guys cuz I live
life I live life I know so let's start
with this number will will dilate down
you know what that means I know it
dilate means man you know but so I read
bro okay but so you read you know you
read Twitter ins so no no I really no
I'm gonna read and comments but no I'm
gonna read soon your tombstone in five
years because you do Oh
it's all good well I'll be there what's
my tombstone gonna saying what are you
gonna say I'm if you know what it said
honestly YouTube's was gonna say he
tried it's gonna be dot dot dot question
mark it's gonna trail off your tombstone
hunter trail off no what are you gonna
say at my funeral if they ask you to
speak I'm gonna honestly go like this
I'll speak and then I'll go on there and
then it'll be like ladies and gentlemen
Chris D'Elia and everyone you know when
they're done cheering or whatever like
my funeral I know I know I'm gonna be
guys guys guys he died guys he died I'm
gonna have to say that a [ __ ] little
[ __ ] load yeah and I'm gonna be up there
with my iced americano sipping and
disrespectful but I know but it's I know
but funerals are early so so uh so I'm
gonna be like guys he lived life and he
he changed the world in the little ways
that people do sometimes and also know
that I'm gonna let out a big [ __ ] rip
fart I'm gonna let out a [ __ ] huge
just [ __ ] oh it's gonna come out like
that and I'm gonna go like this oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry and then I'm gonna take my
sunglasses off and I'm gonna go with my
mouth and I'm gonna [ __ ] have two big
middle fingers I'm not gonna do it like
they do like that but like it I'm gonna
[ __ ] it and the whole thing's and I'm
gonna go like this my news comes out
whenever and whenever time you're using
the launching pad and you're gonna
disrespect me by what sunglasses off in
the middle of it though let's just get
into it man yeah Brian's late eft-1
sends me it takes it goes bro lost track
of time be there soon
who loses track of time I don't even
know what that is by the way I don't
even know what losing track of time is
but here's the problem we've been doing
the show for six years yeah it's the
same time every Wednesday yeah every but
it's so you know it's not like oh it's a
crazy Thursday and yeah except I suppose
won't have a guess it was just me I'm
used to it yeah I did it I used to have
inner demons mmm thing about killing
Brian when he'd be late so I I probably
quit the show four or five times because
he's late all the time yeah
and they stop being late he hasn't been
late in a while yeah it used to be a
real problem
yeah I'm just like a chalking up it's
Brian yeah but you can kind of see that
with Brian's progression in life he lost
track it's always been losing trackers
yeah and now it's really hitting them
and now it's like hey i'ma do a special
it's like I think you lost track of time
yeah that should have been done 15 years
ago but yeah hey good job well boom oh
you would try to bring that foot yeah
but you didn't know Brown has been 87
shades Brown listen up we got a hundred
feet my face with your foot cuz I move
so quickly and I can measure distance
and you would kick and you to overstep
and then your [ __ ] face with you and
I would go yeah yeah I go boop boop boop
I understand combinations boop boop yes
whack and you go meet me and [ __ ] your
pants how did your pants enough to run
away hey how did that guy what was that
guy the Crocodile Hunter rock it out
Dundee no the guy passed away Steve
Irwin Steve Owen now how did he die I'm
already annoyed with this giant [ __ ]
water bottle of yours man you drink too
much water broke you just do if you
drink too much water you can't excuse me
drink enough water I can't take it
how did you see one guy he had he got he
tried to pet a stingray from what I
understand yeah and it's shot it's it's
barb into his heart and God bless the
man he passed away
how BIG's a stingray I don't know will
was probably a very big stingray
probably had a wingspan of about six to
eight feet okay now we're gonna go ahead
and say we're gonna go ahead and put the
over-under at under when we say that my
foot is the size of a stingray it's
probably a little smaller right it's a
little smaller but not by much I don't
believe in getting pedicures okay so if
you come close to me and I'm just
wagging my foot around and I just send a
gnarled yellow
toenail don't into your chest I cut you
don't if I cut you will get you bleed
out
no I'm not touching you get your finger
this is a lot of hot gas getting there
the [ __ ] bro I'm warning you out to me
on the telephone no I can push I can be
pushed
just so far Oh Brian I can be pushed how
are you
that's not my voice well fingers is so
good though I have good skin oh yeah
thank you
hey Nick I look 51 okay no you know you
do have good skin yeah yeah house Rises
a bummer how old are you Nick 41 god
damn dude I've really known you since
you were 19
yeah literally a weird that's crazy that
is [ __ ] weird men you do a good skin
though yeah who's your dermatologist or
bill or that's not I don't even think
it's funny dude so why are you laughing
at your joke you're laughing at your own
joke no I wasn't yeah you were you know
I got a lot of your beard money comes
out of it the funny can I like that I
made you he did not make me no but what
I learned from you is to not do it you
know I like that I molded you and they
didn't hold me at all if I did I broke
it because it was it was him then
crystal you know what weren't you listen
what I mean is I like that you were in
the nest I was feeding my with some no
and then I lay down and night when you
grew feathers I released you and that's
what I know where's my camera there's
only one camera by the way oh you're
talking it's a podcast I understand it
just know that if I want to shoot you
out of the sky they won't happen dude
look oh wow
oh thank god for him huh what you don't
mean what are you doing listening to the
kid right if you really think about it
your turn if you really think about it
if this splits the show split yeah no
one's listening to the [ __ ] it okay dude
that's about what 5% of the [ __ ]
hey you don't know that you I have
metrics watch what happens I have
analytics where do you get those I know
someone here what's his name Korean guy
Koreans not a [ __ ] I'm just saying
Koreans a good complain shins Korea
where's my camera to all my Korean
people you know you're not going no
thanks but no seriously they're already
thinking about the fighter pod is there
any
that even flows good divider block a
point a kid what-who old news bro what
is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]